a gun-toting asgardian a sassy skeleton
weird wigs oil wrestling and bizarre 90s
sitcom parodies what other weird moments
do you remember from xena warrior
princess
it isn't uncommon these days for show
runners and filmmakers to reward fans
for paying careful attention to the end
credits adding hidden details is a
terrific strategy for getting the fandom
together and giving them something to
look for it also creates buzz in online
communities over the latest new treasure
hiding in something as mundane as a
title card or an ongoing credits gag
xena warrior princess was a pioneer in
this realm messages and episodes were so
subtle that even some of the more
attentive fans missed them the first
time around but thanks to the magic of
dvds and streaming video eager fans can
now hit pause during the show's end
credits to find an amusing disclaimer
hidden at the end of most episodes from
ensuring viewers that no mythical
creatures were harmed during the
production of the episode to praising
danny kay's the court jester these silly
disclaimers are a reminder that xena
never took itself too seriously and
viewers shouldn't either
one of the things that made xena special
was the show's ability to balance
serious drama and powerful writing with
plenty of goofy hijinks to lighten up
the mood of all the show's shenanigans
and amusing anachronisms few are more
absurdly wacky than the series odd
mashup of goldie hawn and kurt russell's
1987 film overboard and the fox series
married with children married with fish
sticks had an amnesiac gabrielle duped
by divorce merman hagar into believing
she was the mother of his out of control
brood to make things extra loony the
oceanic parallel world was rife with
doppelgangers from gabby's real life
plagued with strange and surreal horrors
like bad fashion catty neighbors and a
misogynistic husband gabby's new reality
was a nightmare but it was their three
out of control offspring that kept
viewers up at night wondering what
they'd seen unable to get those images
out of their heads in order from oldest
to youngest gabrielle met three children
straight out of special effects
purgatory walrus boy flipper mini hell
priest urchin and the octopus adjacent
baby roe at once horrifying and weirdly
cute roe was one of the most puzzling
creatures dreamed up by xena creators
the meme potential alone garners plenty
of pauses among viewers today
salon writer andrew leonard was spot on
when he called the xena halloween
episode girls just want to have fun the
disco-lesbian vampire episode starring a
lord darkness from legend lookalike as
bacchus the episode had a little
something for everyone there was a dance
party possessed wolves and a random
musician's disembodied but still
completely animated head attached to
everything from pikes to scarecrows the
production team got so carried away with
all of this crazy music video energy
that they even forgot to edit out a
propane tank which can be seen in all
its anachronistic glory but it's the
super sultry vampire lust in this
episode that solidified its place in the
annals of tv thurstom helping shape the
show's image as an iconic lesbian love
story since vampirism has always been
used as a metaphor for sexuality the
show's creators decided to use the
bakaye as a pre-hellenic stand-in for
vampires it let them sneakily explore
gabrielle and xena's sexuality in a way
that wasn't standard for the era
director tj scott told xena magazine
that he and lucy lawless set out to push
the envelope in terms of sexual content
the result was a super hot scene with
gotheed out gabby and xena lost in
erotic vamp bliss
some xena warrior princess story arcs
are darker than others such as the
altitail once a siberian amazon alti was
booted by her tribe when she became a
power hungry shaman she would go on to
become a toxic frenemy to a still evil
xena she worked to manipulate the young
chakram wielder into murdering the
entire amazon tribe under the promise
the shaman would make xena a destroyer
of nations this is war zener
just a little one
although xena would live up to this
title alti failed to tell her it came
with a curse the dark shaman placed the
curse on her lover barias and unborn son
solon costing barias his life and solon
his parents if that super heavy
backstory wasn't enough it got even
darker eventually a reformed xena
journeyed with the northern amazons to
the amazon resting place there she was
forced to confront the skeletons of the
amazons she once killed in the name of
power but in the midst of this dark
moment if you look carefully you'll see
one sassy skeleton flipping the bird in
its final moments
there are countless reasons to love carl
urban if you're paying close attention
he's everywhere he looked majestic as
heck in his fair garb and glorious
golden locks as eomer in the lord of the
rings as a super salty but sweet bones
he's a bright spot in the oft divisive
j.j abrams star trek films he pops up in
thor ragnarok as scourge he even had a
star wars cameo these days he can be
found in his breakthrough role as billy
butcher on the boys of course xena fans
have been on team urban since the late
90s when he first appeared on both xena
and hercules the legendary journeys
urban's appearance on the two shows were
some of his earliest roles and he didn't
miss a chance to display his acting
chops on xena he showed up in four
different roles often looking barely
recognizable thanks to the magic of a
great hair and makeup department he
first appeared as mael a psychopathic
ancient greek version of the biblical
isaac's half-brother urban later spent
eight episodes as zena's handsome lover
and murderer julius caesar he then took
on more of a comic role donning wings
and bleached hair as aphrodite's son
cupid finally he played a stone age
cannibal named core alongside selma
blair in lifeblood an episode that was
meant to be a backdoor pilot for the
scrapped series amazon high
like carl urban gina torres is one of
those actors that keeps taking roles in
iconic series that sci-fi fans fall in
love with long before her appearance on
hercules and xena torres had been
building a reputation as a solid
television and film actor and post xena
she continued with roles on firefly
angel and westworld to name a few most
recently she can be found as a main cast
member on 9-1-1 lone star where she
plays emt tommy vega fans of torres
watching xena warrior princess for the
first time will be thrilled when she
turns up as the perfectly eyelinered
cleopatra in the king of assassins yet
another doppelganger episode it places
cleopatra jockster atollicus gabrielle
and xena in the middle of fresh mistaken
identity mayhem courtesy of jockster's
much cooler evil twin jet while much of
the episode revolves around thwarting a
plot to kill cleo there's a whole thing
going on between the queen of egypt and
our favorite king of thieves it's
complete with a steamy bathtub scene and
enough double entendres to fill a trojan
horse
back in the 1990s lgbtq representation
was rare and typically poorly executed
in the 90s every time anyone or anything
dared to be out and proud some people
really lost their minds over it it was
also a time when tv producers had even
less autonomy when it came to their
production and writing decisions than
they do today from the show's beginning
the network was aware of the possibility
that the relationship between gabby and
xena could be perceived as romantic so
they went out of their way to forbid any
clear-cut lesbian relationship but what
about subtext as it turns out the
network was fine with lgbtq subtext
especially since it became clear pretty
quickly that the subtext was part of
what fans kept coming back to see found
it
ah
i found it
[Applause]
i learned from the best
audiences ended up with plenty of steamy
scenes where the heroes were bathing
together washing each other's backs and
having heartfelt conversations about how
they couldn't live without each other
for those of us who lived to see those
super shippable moments there were
plenty of opportunities to hit the pause
button there are goodbye kisses like in
the episode the return of kalisto there
are substitute body kisses like when
xena kisses gabby and atella kiss's body
there are four head kisses cheek kisses
life-saving kisses and gothy vampire
kisses and every one of them looks great
as smartphone wallpaper
anyone who writes or reads fanfiction
knows that some fantasies are better
kept private a lesson jockster learns
the hard way in the quill is mightier
see while xena and gabrielle were
forging a bond that would last for
eternity their goofy friend joxer was
not so secretly holding a torch for
gabrielle one of the great things about
joxer's relationship with the heroes is
that no matter how knee deep and cringe
he was at all times xena and gabrielle
always loved and respected him they even
had empathy for his feelings about gabby
nonetheless he could be incredibly
annoying and he never seemed to tire of
pushing the limits of the girl's
tolerance but when aphrodite suddenly
gifted gabrielle the power to write her
reality mayhem ensued after conjuring
and obsessively fishing xena and some
various troubles for the gods gaby got
the bright idea to have all the victims
of her writing sleep in a nearby cave
until she could work out a solution amid
the mess a bad attempt at love poetry
manifested jockster's gabby fantasies as
three naked dancing gabrielles thanks to
some fun camera work the scene remained
fairly g-rated but it still became one
of the silliest sites in the entire
series if only all bad writing was so
innocuous
generally speaking big budget films and
higher caliber tv shows will go out of
their way to conceal stunt doubles other
entertainment options don't seem to be
terribly concerned perhaps it's because
the director is confident the scenes
will go so fast or their audience will
be so dazzled by their sleight of hand
that they won't look too closely or
perhaps they're just working with a
limited time frame and budget so they do
the best they can under those
constraints and move on to the next shot
but some productions just don't even
seem to care and not every actor can
have a near perfect photo double like
says from only murderers in the building
is that filler i'm over here
what the
what is this face off either way the
results can be pretty amusing when stunt
doubles are obvious and xena warrior
princess was a frequent offender this
was especially comical for a series that
spent so much time focusing on
doppelganger gags things seemed to go
off the rails at some point during
season 4 when blatant stunt doubles
became a common sight one good example
of this guaranteed to make you laugh is
when an obvious stunt double can be seen
riding argo in the episode end game
sooner or later everybody reaches the
breaking point where it's time to just
phone it in that seems to be exactly
what happened in if the shoe fits when
for no clear reason gabrielle
inexplicably had the most absurd wig in
one scene only in the episode a burlap
sack clad gabrielle tells a young
runaway princess her version of the
cinderella story starring herself as the
lovely and put upon tyrella throughout
the episode each of gabrielle's
companions take over storytelling at
some point with aphrodite jockster and
xena each giving it their own spin while
the story within a story featured some
pretty fancy wigs and costumes back in
real life gabrielle was still hanging
around in a burlap sack that's why it's
that much more puzzling when she's
randomly seen rifling through her
belongings while wearing a bizarrely
poofy much redder wig sometimes you just
have to work with what you've got on
hand so you can clock out in time for
happy hour
there are some episodes of xena that
beautifully capture the profound
complexity and depth of the human
experience touching the hearts and souls
of yours then there are the others
little problems begins with xena body
swapping with a little girl in a coma
and things only get worse from there
aphrodite and gabrielle are plotting to
steal some magic soul dividing oil from
club owners and skeezy conjoined twins
castor and pollux for some reason their
convoluted plan involves pretending to
be swedish conjoined twins and oil
wrestling the brothers to get into their
exclusive twins only club the episode is
all over the place but the nonsensical
scenes with gabrielle and aphrodite
pretending to be valkyrie twins are
worth the price of admission alone check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite tv shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]